[Musique]
beaucoup de français pour l'instant ne
veulent pas d'astrazeneca ya beaucoup on
l'évoquait ya un instant il ya beaucoup
de français qui des commandes leur
rendez-vous de vaccination beaucoup qui
n'ont pas confiance alors après il faut
bien le dire un peu le flottement qui a
eu la suspension de quelques jours des
vaccins par l' agence européenne du
médicament et puis il ya toujours ces
cas de trompes aux il faut le redire ils
sont ultra minoritaires moins de 1 pour
1 million de personnes vaccinées mais la
situation sanitaire qui continue de
stagner en france 5959 ce patient était
en réanimation hier soit 25 de moins que
la veille
le gouvernement maintient malgré tout
son calendrier la fin des restrictions
de déplacement le 3 mai et la
réouverture des commerces à partir de la
mi mai tandis que jean castex a émis le
nom avancé le nom de de sheila me
remettais moi sourit régis la une de la
dépêche
regardez-moi ça jean castex veut il veut
faire vacciner chez là pour redorer
l'image souvenirs d'enfant sans doute il
veille marc mais chela je vous passe
tous les jeux de mots hier industeel
chez la bonne solution
chez la lutte finale pour toi le coc
vide certains ont des idées de spectacle
on va remplacer le concert des [ __ ]
par le concert des inoculé suggéra
d'internautes
d'autres imaginent déjà la tournée astra
80 vaches et là
et ainsi nous pas en résumé selon un
internaute cette idée risque plus de
relancer la carrière de sheila que celle
d'astrazeneca
car la chanteuse âgée de 75 ans est en
pleine forme vient de sortir un album
que jean castex et coûte sûrement à fond
un match bien bien sûr comme vous le
savez jean castex a demandé à des stars
comme moi de faire la promotion du
vaccin
je les fais il y à 24 heures et la ga
lucet n'ai aucune douleur
aucun problème j'ai déjà hâte de me
rendre mon masque dans cette boutique
musée donc du riz des pâtes du café du
papier toilette dans des packagings
exclusif les assemblages de légumes
respecte les canons de l'art moderne
un critique d'art facétieux explique au
visiteur le sens profond de la carotte
avez-vous bien consommer vos cinq
oeuvres d'art par jour interroge ce
panonceau
[Musique]
bilé bilé
j'arrive dans le club et j'ai posé le
dans b g montreux songe morgan am to
work est dommage la féclaz les patrons
je pensais que tous les rappeurs tous
les chanteurs en fait que c'était facile
que ce n'était pas un travail mon voyant
ça de plus près on fait ça à vrai
travail d'enregistrer à son c'est long
ça prend du temps et c'est très
compliqué c'est un vrai média c'est pas
donné à tout le monde
quatre audiences quitter
[Musique]
des toits
en parlant mon cadeau de noël tu verras
tu verras et donc le jour venu bas on
prend la voiture on fait une heure et
demie de route mais je sais toujours pas
où on va
et en fait il me dit dans la voiture ben
voilà on va dans un club échangiste et
moi j'étais ouais bon ont fêté noël
bah c'est beau cadeau de noël en fait on
voit là et franchement je n'étais pas
bien du tout
[Musique]
déboussolés ils ne semblent pas
comprendre pourquoi les gendarmes sont
intervenus chez lui mardi sonia mabrouk
rooney sur le sujet dans son émission
made in your sur ces news et donner la
parole à son intervenante elisabeth lévy
dans ces quartiers vous n'avez plus de
boucherie non halal vous fait insulter
si vous mangez pendant ramadan et
compris d'ailleurs si vous avez une tête
d'arabe
une sortie qui n'a pas manqué de faire
réagir sonia mabrouk il a directement
aux cadres et et qui lui a demandé si
elle avait elle aussi une tête d'arabe
ce à quoi elle a répondu oui ce soit que
vous êtes vous à une origine mais ça n'a
rien de saint constant
la remarque la plus sexiste entendu dans
le milieu du journalisme y en a une qui
me revient c'est un patron qui parlait
d'une jeune femme et qui n'y a
maintenant mais d'autres sont à l' on
peut pas compter sur ray allen nous
plante est en fait cette femme était en
congé maternité
elisabeth est ce que j'ai une tête
d'arabe c'est un peu après son départ a
justement à tout pays
voici yuuwaa la première ville martienne
tels que la souhaiterait elon musk
le milliardaire se verrait bien s'y
installer dans moins de dix ans un
projet fou celui de la colonisation de
mars qui fascine les scientifiques cette
semaine une marche de plus a été gravie
grâce à persévérance le robot de la nasa
posait sur la planète rouge en février
dernier à fabriquer de l'oxygène une
première
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les scientifiques sont divisés sur la
faisabilité d'un tel projet mais
s'accordent sur un point
de nombreux obstacles techniques
empêchent encore ce grand voyage
certains pensent qu'on ne pourra jamais
y aller d'autres considèrent eux on en
fera d'abord le tour et qu'on réussira à
se poser et à revenir ce sera une
démonstration un peu stérile et d'autres
comme il l'admet ce que pense qu'on
pourra s'y établir et qu'on y établira
des colonies là c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup mieux vaut juste croire d'émail
ou un tableau la faute aux intrigues cet
internaute
il s'agit en fait de vélo à shenyang
dans le nord est de la chine ce sont des
milliers et des milliers de vélos qui
sont laissés ici à l'abandon la cause
l'explosion des vélos en libre-service
l'offre était beaucoup trop forte
à chaque couleur ici correspond une
marque entre les vélos cassés délaissés
et les stocks des entreprises en
faillite ce terrain vague ne cesse de se
remplir
est ce que vous lisez là bah oui moi
aussi je lui colle à la peau est très
commercial en tout cas non mais c'est
tendance